Paulie says we have a mystery phone
caller we'd beat the the calls are
coming in to thank us and congratulate
us on 10 years is that right Paul on the
hotline the bread truck
the Auburn power-forward the round mound
of rebound Charles party yes hi Charles
hey Dan hey Charles I got a couple
things I need to get off of my chest
this is the first interview I've done
this week
so I want to congratulate you on 10
magnificent years thank you
you know I got a love for you and your
crew but I've been in bed since Monday
night I have not moved out of my bed
since Monday night because I had the
Washington Redskins in that game so you
you know how special you are
he's eating me out of here to call you
have you had a beat worse than that one
on Monday night well you know what
happened did she wants to Vanderbilt
Florida game oh yeah I had Vandy in that
game oh wait I gotta get this one yard
and the game was gonna be out of her
over and this dude takes it to the house
so I'm like it can't get any worse than
the vendee Florida game and then these
damn idiots from the riskiness try this
play and man let me tell yourself I I
cannot believe it just in Houston who
was those thud I wanted to jump through
the television set just choke the hell
out of justice because he's a flat out
but I cannot oh my god that is my worst
beatdown ever I'm not gonna lie
well why don't you tell me who you're
betting against and then I'll go the
other side and make some money wait
first of all dad that was a lot bet if
you kick a field
go with 1015 seconds ago in the game you
should win that game true but you know
what I had to call in and congratulate
your 10 years the man I've been landing
this [ __ ] at Monday night about twelve
thirty five but um you know what that
I'm gonna give up gambling no you're not
until tonight
Charles thank you for calling it too
late there's two games tonight there's
NC State Louisville and the Buccaneers
against a pager so I gave up gambling
for three days it took me a little while
to get over that beat down Monday night
thank you for calling in Charles and
thank you for allowing us to have you
part of our program the last ten years
you do that I'm surprised I didn't think
you was gonna make it to go you're not
alone you're not alone no seriously you
got a perfect place for radio when they
start putting your face on television I
said the way he looked is not gonna last
long
you're not gonna make it Thank You
Charles thank you hey man I need one
more favor from you
okay got a hurry tell-tell Rich Eisen
it's time to come on home
shave his them here he's holding on for
dear life and I have no idea why tell
him to come on home is over he lost
Thank you Thank You Charles
it's it's Charles Barkley the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience